hi everyone i'm john cena i'm going to
be put in a date like scenario with
people whom asked me questions this
should be very fun
[Music]
hey John Xena I'm super excited for a
date and I just saw the movie blockers
so I was wondering if you had to but
chug a beer
what kind of beer would you butt chug
and why that's a great question
you ever seen a four ounce can of
Budweiser that's why because it's a four
ounce cap hey John if you could only
read one book for the rest of your life
which work would it
I don't have jerky but a simple melody
it can answer this question the simple
work of one book compiling all books in
the history of mankind which would cut
off today so I wouldn't get anything
past today but like if the Library of
Congress were to make one book out of
all their material man I started off
good thinking all I needed was a chorus
and then it kind of got into spoken word
and now I'm just answering the question
shucks if I only had jerky I'm so
excited for a first date I'm excited it
was like scenario do you mean you I'm
asking
if you--if you have seen anything that
I've been a part of yes from I'm here
down is well taken care of so yes
there's no other way to answer yes
first day that depends in this date like
scenario I'm gonna pass because I would
be licking a LED screen which is uh I
think it's fetish worthy but I don't
know for all I think it weirds people
out but if it's with the right person
yes it's old person in the black dress
I'm just gonna call you gold necklace
because I feel we're there already what
makes me cry well there are different
types of crying we all know that there's
the type of cry when you're depressed
and you're kind of down on yourself
there's the type of emotional cry when
you watch the notebook there's also the
type of happy cry when you watch
something like a moment in sport where
maybe your team wins for the first time
and so long and you cry tears of joy all
of those things kind of move me as well
as like weird dramas too I cried during
watching the darkest hour it gives you
the kind of an idea of where I'm at as a
crier
but I think we're there already so I
could show them hey John Cena before I
go on a date with anybody I have to know
the answer to this very important
question do you believe in ghosts
you've already sunk your own ship
because we're already on a date like
scenario which means that you're lying
only to yourself you can't go around
saying things like I only do this if I
get the answer to this question because
we're already here this has already
happened so you're not a person of your
work which means you can't be trusted
which means you have to work on yourself
establish trust and that totally got me
out of the question of you I believe it
goes to not which I'm pretty proud of if
for some reason I had a giant pimple on
my back and I could not reach it would
you pop it for me
we're virtually meeting
and you're asking me to be an
aesthetician I am not qualified nor do I
want to possess the skills of an
aesthetician and therefore there
probably would be some medical concern
in the incorrect practice of me taking
care of your lesion oil warts
whatever you would call the growth on
your back I would just see it and only
hit which would lead to awkward
conversation I wanted to know why are
your top five favorite movies top 5
favorite movies those are good questions
I was enthralled by the concept of the
matrix so I'll say the matrix I love
this the way Star Wars tells movies so I
must say Star Wars 2001 Space Odyssey is
real good
Caddyshack is in there a big Dangerfield
guy and I'm gonna quit with four leaving
one open for debate because when I give
my list everybody would be like I can't
believe he picked those movies and
didn't pick this movie well I'm leaving
you one spot so you can put your movie
in there I want to know what you're
working on right now because I saw you
in trainwreck and I haven't seen
blockers yet but I know you're in it
what are you working on now that's a
great question
head on over to YouTube red where you
can see Dallas and Robo which is an
animated series it's quite exciting it
as myself and cat Denning and remember
it's on YouTube read John Cena here
after I've experienced speed virtual
question dating it's awesome and kind of
awkward when I do it again sure
[Music]